well Apple is betting big on a
partnership with Hollywood to counter
slowing sales of its devices
the tech giant unveiled its move into
subscription streaming entertainment
yesterday during a splashy event at at
Silicon Valley headquarters Jamie yuccas
shows us Apple's new strategy Apple TV
CEO Tim Cook brought out the megawatt
star power the apples do streaming
subscription service the Hollywood icon
Steven Spielberg a whole new batch of
amazing stories there has never been a
moment quite like this one
Oprah Winfrey will debut new
documentaries exclusively on the service
she said the decision to join Apple was
easy because they're in a billion
pockets all a billion pockets Apple's
iPhone sales were up and down last year
but bounced back with nearly 52 billion
in sales in the first three months of
this year Apple needs to make money and
they're not selling a lot of iPhones or
not as many as they used to CNET news
editor-in-chief Connie G Elmo says Apple
is pivoting we're used to Apple
introducing iPhones and iPads and
computers and this is a big investment
and this event today demonstrates that
they want to start making a lot more
money from services as demand for some
of their hardware tips apple also
announced a new credit card Plus
subscription news and gaming services
a reoccurring theme throughout they're
designed to keep your personal
information private and secure securing
users privacy and data they are taking
the stand that they are the privacy
advocate for CBS this morning Jamie
yuccas Cupertino California Oprah said
it best there in a billion pocketed all
right quite the roll out there ready
it's like that